le moment qu'on attend tous les
délibérations du prix renaudot des
lycéens organisé par les amis de
théophraste renaudot et le rectorat de
l'académie de poitiers ont eu lieu ce
matin jeudi 14 novembre 2019 le prix
renaudot des lycéens 2019 a été attribué
à victoria masse pour son roman le bal
des folles publié aux éditions albin
michel qui a séduit le jury du prix
renaudot des lycéens par sont aimé
l'originalité de l'histoire
les portraits de femmes complexe et
attachante et par un sujet qui nous
touche en tant qu'être humain est aussi
on trouve que femme ce roman est élu à
15 euros devant alexis michalik pour son
roman loin
publié aux éditions albin michel ça
l'était pas en fait c'est un avis global
pour tout le monde en fait tous les
lycées ça a été leur coup de coeur en
fête ce livre ça a été vraiment les
préférés de tous les lycées loin était
quand même c'était quand même assez
serrée entre les deux parce qu'elle fait
la différence et l'histoire en fait ça
révèle marche de de féminisme et c'est
ça qui a plus cette condition de femme
au 19e siècle
ça a énormément plu les personnages les
portraits de très très touchant et ça
nous a tous plus et nous c'était super
et puis s'était majoritairement des
filles qui ont des garçons aussi donner
leurs rollers leurs opinions et ça
faisait du bien d'avoir un avis masculin
du jour ce secteur qui a quand même été
rédigé par une fille une femme et aussi
à destination d'un public féminin
mais il ya des garçons qui ont donné
leur avis et ça nous a fait du bien de
de les savoir justement de les prendre
en compte visiter quand même les avis
il y avait au moins un garçon qui a
trouvé ce livre génial génial choisi
parce que en fait nous on ne savait pas
on n'a pas appris ça à l'école la teneur
des femmes à cette époque au 19e siècle
vous a jamais parlé de la s'appelle de
la chapelle de la salpêtrière et de
femmes internées pour maladie mentale
voilà c'était très intéressant
un contexte qu'on ne connaissait pas
qu'on nous a jamais appris à l'école
mais il sait très bien racontée dans ce
livre il est facile et rapide la lui en
très peu de temps plus et voilà comment
c'était un livre à dévorer faites-vous
les lycées avaient fait de choix après
un principaux et le bal des folles en
faisait partie
pour tous voilà c'est fait à l'unanimité
à la merci voilà on a quand même fait 2
2 tours mais même au premier il avait le
plus de votes les plus de voix c'est ce
qui est bien avec ce prise et que ça
nous a permis de deux livres parce que
nous d'habitude avec le lycée on n'a pas
beaucoup le temps de lire entre les
à lire dans nos matières et là ça nous a
permis justement de le dire aussi
d'aider des romans contemporains plus
voilà et autres que les livres de
français racing victor hugo tout ça tu
sais c'est pour ça que ça nous a voilà
cette année ça nous aura permis d vers
d'autres ni moins pour ma part je lis
beaucoup de fiction tout ça et je lis
pas forcément d'oeuvre qui raconte une
histoire vraie hélas mmx sse et des
personnages inventés hormis sharks où
est le lieu aussi à paris l'admettaient
augustine apparemment mai et moi j'ai
bien aimé ce mix de de fiction et de
faits réels
voilà c'est ça oui je suis on était
vraiment beau temps et des grands
laiterie cela fait deux ans que je
participe lui jamais deux sans trois
voilà voici la première année
franchement c'est une super découverte
j'adore vraiment le conseil pour pouvoir
débattre avec les autres
l'autre au lycée dans toute la france et
même d'accord que on sentait qu'il y
avait quand même à une attirance pour
les deux premiers au moins on a les deux
premiers là franchement on n'y pensait
sérieusement le bal des folles est
vraiment un moment très agréable à lire
intéressant qui questionnent beaucoup
l'histoire
et puis les personnages je pense que là
effectivement c'est peut-être une écurie
un peu féminine féministes comme l'a dit
on l'a dit tout à l'heure mais moi je
suis pas du tout surprise du choix parce
qu'à chaque fois les lycées à nous nous
réserve de belles surprises et surtout
des lectures de qualité et c'est
formidable
voilà pour un premier roman plus d'avoir
le prix renaudot des lycéens s'étaient
alors la bibliothèque départementale
participe donc à la sélection enfin nous
voilà donc c'est donc l'action
culturelle service action culturelle
donc ma personnes ont participé à la
sélection
on se retrouve tous autour d'une table
c'est un moment très très agréable parce
que évidemment on a la liste des
renaudot l'eurusd de national et à
partir de cette liste
on doit donc choisir les cinq titres qui
seront proposés à la lecture des lycéens
donc notre participation la bibliothèque
départementale c'est une participation
technique jeu direct ou tard les voilà
c'est une aide au choix
mais on fait partie de la boucle
d'échangés alors après mois de décembre
c'est vrai que notre participation
niveau de la bibliothèque départementale
elle a commencé aussi dans l'optique de
d'ouvrir le prix au tout public donc de
travailler en étroit partenariat avec la
médiathèque de boudin puisque la biotech
départemental c'est le service lecture
du département mais surtout public un
les lycéens font partie du grand public
aussi
donc le soir lorsque la l'auteur oran
tenir toute la journée les lycéens
le soir il ya un moment sous publique
organisée donc alidade et nous on
participe en proposant le nom et le
soutien pour la venue d'un journaliste
littéraire qui chaque année présente
l'auteur remontera un choisi l'écrivain
a choisi allons somme de la population
que ce soit lui donne aussi toutes les
communes autour donc une centaine de
personnes se réunissent donc voilà les
lectures n'est pas le lycée elle est
tout public
elle concerne tout le monde ah c'est une
belle édition parce que d'abord il y
avait une belle sélection six livres de
beaux livres variés et puis bal hélicéa
ils sont tous les ans de plus en plus
jeunes
de plus en plus pugnace et enthousiaste
et puis franchement le travail le
travail des enseignants à extraordinaire
parce que ils ont quand même du mérite
avec le travail qu'ils doivent faire
l'intérieur des programmes mais aussi
avec bell des difficultés de tous ordres
et ils réussissent à faire lire les
livres aux élèves des ce1 franchement
moi je tire mon chapeau
il faut mentir les cassandre qui pensent
que la lecture n'existe plus mais si
elle existe et nous la propose aussi en
numérique livre numérique assure le
corail sur les sites de la bibliothèque
départementale dans tous ses livres
aussi on les retrouve dans une façon
différente